[Música]
este día se conmemora la fundación de
Israel en 1948 pero el aniversario
número 75 que el Primer Ministro
Benjamín netayajo ha promovido como una
fiesta de la unidad nacional no ha
alcanzado ese tono empañado por una de
las crisis más graves de Israel en toda
su historia ante el proyecto de reformas
judiciales que promueve el propio
premiere las reformas están en pausa de
momento dadas las protestas masivas que
se oponen a los cambios por ser
benéficos con el gobernante y ayudarlo a
fortalecerse en el poder además de
favorecer lo posiblemente en las causas
de corrupción que enfrenta sin embargo
este aniversario va más allá cargado de
simbolismos y de recordatorios del
conflicto que existe con los territorios
palestinos vamos a ir al análisis con
Ezequiel Coppel a quienes analista
experto en medio oriente y autor de los
libros de la disputa por el control de
medio oriente y medio oriente lugar
común señor Coppel é bienvenido directo
América Gracias por atendernos
mire el Primer Ministro de Israel y
Benjamín Busca insertar un mensaje de
unidad ante la fractura social que Es
evidente y que desató su propio gobierno
con la reforma judicial que primará en
este 75 aniversario de la fundación del
estado
a ver yo creo que lo que va a primar va
a ser la continuidad de un conflicto
israelí en este momento sería realista
partida y claramente lo que está pasando
es está buscando un rumbo esta partida
entre una alianza conformada por el
nacionalistas mesiánicos ortodoxos
derechistas seculares contra otro Polo
manifestado en personas principalmente
seculares que son las que digamos
toleran el peso del estado es el que más
pagan impuestos las que más van al
ejército recargan principalmente con el
peso del estado y lo que ellos sostienen
es que Israel se está volviendo un país
antidemocrático y que es libertad y la
separación de poderes están amenazadas
por el avance el intento de la coalición
de avanzar sobre sobre la separación de
poderes yo lo que veo es un conflicto
que va a continuar la verdad hasta que
sigue este gobierno claro Hay que
recordarles a los televidentes que esta
reforma judicial le permitiría al
ejecutivo nombrar y también destituir
jueces le permitiría netanyahu tener
ventaja en los juicios de corrupción en
el juicio de corrupción que enfrenta en
este momento y una habilidad además al
parlamento para limitar los
pronunciamientos y las decisiones del
supremo ahora frente a este panorama que
ha sido ampliamente contestado y que
finalmente ha tenido que poner en pausa
el gobernante qué carta se le quedan a
netanyahu con su reforma versus la
verdadera promoción de unidad en el país
que en este momento es inexistente
eres un problema ni siempre se ha
vendido como un político que se ha
parado en el medio entre dos extremos es
decir siempre su estrategia fue
acercar a los componentes más extremos
de la política israelí y el pararse en
el medio Y de alguna manera moderarlos
yo creo que en este momento él se ve
atado a la colisión que ha formado y si
él quisiera parar la reforma judicial la
coalición se va a caer porque la
colisión realmente se formó para que
avanzar todos estos estas estas reformas
del estado de reforma contra la
separación de poderes es decir lo que lo
que veo es es una imposibilidad de
netanyahu de volver a ser el detalla
Jude antes de decir además que él él ve
que si para la reforma judicial lo que
muchos dicen llaman golpe judicial
automáticamente tarde o temprano el
poder judicial va a ir contra él iba a
tener que dejar el cargo de Primer
Ministro Entonces yo lo que veo es una
pausa en este momento ante una nueva
batalla entre estos dos sectores un
completo sin salida y quiero hablar de
otro tema con usted que ha quedado
completamente invisibilizado en medio de
la crisis en este aniversario y es labra
la brecha tan grande que existe con el
problema más antiguo de Israel respecto
de los palestinos apenas está
mencionándose a pesar de un reciente
aumento de la violencia en los
territorios palestinos y en las zonas
ocupadas
Bueno Este es el gran lo que muchos
otros llamamos el elefante en el en el
cuarto el elefante escondido en el
cuarto es el tema que no se quiere
hablar es decir mucha gente que está
manifestándose en Israel pidiendo que
haya separación de poderes que no es que
no haya avances contra la democracia
israelí parece que se olvidan de que la
mitad de la población bajo control
israelí que son los palestinos tumados a
los israelíes árabes a los árabes
israelíes que viven dentro de Israel que
tienen derechos digamos en algunas
cuestiones un poco limitadas Bueno tu tu
sus libertades y sus potestades de
alguna manera que están limitadas
entonces de alguna manera Acá hay un
tema que es que hay muchas personas que
están manifestándose contra el gobierno
israelí que están están enojadas por los
avances contra sus libertades pero que
están que no están dispuestos a no mirar
El Avance contra las libertades o los
derechos civiles de los palestinos que
están ocupados podemos decir de alguna
manera que luego de más de 35 años de
independencia israelí
75 años de provincia israelí y más de 55
años de ocupación entre los palestinos
la ocupación de los palestinos no es un
hecho fortuito un hecho parcial o un
hecho circunstancial la ocupación de los
palestinos de hace mucho tiempo es parte
de la política nacional israelí ese me
parece que es el elefante en el cuarto
que la mayoría de los israelíes incluso
que están marchando contra las
intenciones
dictatoriales en hallazgos están
olvidando Me parece que de alguna manera
también de Israel quiere mantener la tu
democracia bueno de alguna manera
también tiene que llegar a un acuerdo
con los palestinos sino es como que de
alguna manera todo el tiempo se va
mordiendo la cola para mantener la
ocupación de los palestinos Israel cada
vez tiene que volver más antidemocrático
claro es que algunos incluso hablan de
que se puede decir que hay un estado
judío o un estado democrático pero ambas
cosas no son compatibles en las
condiciones actuales finalmente ya para
cerrar si tiene cosas que celebrar
Israel aunque no se note dado el
conflicto interno que hay logros o como
una potencia económica como una potencia
militar de la región trace una población
que resurgió del holocausto que decir de
esto para el cierre
más poderoso de medio oriente es un país
fuerte es un país fuerte militarmente
económicamente Incluso en sus aspectos
sociales es muy fuerte pero el gran
problema de Israel es que todavía no ha
podido definir sus fronteras Entonces es
un país me parece para nada llamarlo
fallido etcétera es un país que no puede
completarse es decir Incluso si podemos
decir que el sionismo logró un estado
nacional para los judíos es el sionismo
no ha logrado de dictaminar o establecer
fronteras para el Estado judío y me
parece que ese es un gran problema al no
establecer fronteras al Estado judío
como no logra terminar como como con su
propósito histórico Y de alguna manera
ese propósito histórico no se puede
terminar y no se llega a un acuerdo con
los palestinos y no se puede lograr una
paz en el territorio pues mire como
siempre Israel un tema que genera muchas
cuestiones y que no tiene resoluciones
vamos a ver qué sucede con el tema
político y con Benjamín de tanyahu Yo le
agradezco mucho por entregar nos su
perspectiva y su análisis en esta mañana
y a nuestros televidentes Les pedimos
que sigan conectados con nosotros
pequeña pausa ya volvemos con más de
directo a América
[Música]